good morning believe nation today's
message is stop bullying yourself over
to you Katy Perry for a long time
people we're talking about bullying and
that was a big hot topic and I think
sometimes you can forget that you could
be your own bully in some way it's like
you are the person that is standing in
the way of your success whether it's
professionally or personally and
honestly that was the case for me I was
having a great professional streak but
personally I was really immature and so
I had to balance them out finally I had
enough and I said hey you need to speak
up for yourself if you're not happy with
something you change it you know change
it make yourself better every single day
so I went to a lot of therapy and I I
guess I put it in the way of like you're
gonna hear me roar finally you're I'm
gonna be able to speak up for myself
I think we're too hard on ourselves not
just entrepreneurs but people which is
too hard on ourselves we are our own
worst critic and we are our biggest
roadblock to achieve greatness to
achieve that big goal to have that big
impact the biggest thing that is holding
you back is you and your judgments
because we want to have the perfect
Facebook picture and you spend two hours
taking that perfect Instagram picture
and your life doesn't match the facade
that you're creating out there and so
you judge yourself and you're hard on
yourself and you don't start that
YouTube channel because you make a video
and you hate it and you judge yourself
and so you take it down you don't take
on that next new project because you're
afraid of failing and how that's going
to make you feel you don't say yes to
that project you don't say yes to that
creative thing that you really really
really want to do that's always been
burning inside you but you don't take
action on it because you're afraid
because far worse than anybody else's
opinions and judgement of you is your
own judgement and opinion of yourself
you don't want to fail yourself and so
you stay living small I'm reminded of
Lily who's one of our turn events also
instructors and one of the things that I
love that she does at the end of every
class is whoever's in rotation River has
partnered up you know men and women
partnered up together she'll have them
at the end of class share one thing that
they really liked about the other person
so yes we're here to learn dance moves
but it's also much more it's about being
a family it's about gaining confidence
nobody comes here to be the best salsa
dancer in the world it's not why people
sign up they want something fun to do
they want to make new friends and want
to gain more confidence and so at the
end of the class she has the man and a
woman share one thing that they liked
about the other person maybe they were
really funny or maybe they really
laughed and maybe they really liked how
they executed one of those moves
whatever it was sure one genuine thing
for a lot of people that's the only
compliment they've received all day
that's kind of sad but she did something
new this week that I really loved and
she swapped it we're at the end of the
class she asked them share one thing
with the other person that you love
about yourself and it was surprising how
difficult a time people had trying to
figure out just one thing that they
loved about themselves some people
struggled with it
some people got emotional about it we
give ourselves way too hard a time and
we need to give ourselves permission to
fail to suck at things to try things to
explore to not know the answer sometimes
and it's through that path through that
pain through that discovery through the
falling down through the failure through
the heartaches through all those tough
times that that's when you emerge to
create something amazing to create that
best version of yourself that you can
really own and grow and have a big
impact on the world because as long as
you're living small as long as you're so
afraid to do anything because you're
worried about failing and how that might
look to yourself you're so judgmental
critical the work that you do that you
never release anything then you're never
going to have that big impact so stop
bullying yourself and start being your
own best cheerleader instead so the
question today today is how are you
bullying yourself leave it down in the
comments below
hopefully by sharing it you'll release
it and you
the support of belief nation behind you
- so leave in the comments below I'm
gonna join in the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso